PROBE AND SEE WHAT I SEE AND
THEN IF I DON'T LIKE IT THEN I
ALWAYS HAVE -- USING HIM AS THE
SAFETY NET SOMETIMES ON THREE
OUT OF FIVE POSSESSIONS INSTEAD
OF THE NET ALL THE TIME.
AND I THINK THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY, CHUCK --
>> WHEN THEY GET A REBOUND --
>> THEY'RE LOOKING FOR HIM.
>> HE STARTS DOING THAT RIGHT
AWAY.
NO, MAN, GO.
>> I'M GOING TO LOOK YOU OFF.
>> LISTEN, WHAT I SAID, YOUR
STAR IS SUPPOSED TO BRING YOU
HOME.
BUT LIKE I'M NOT GOING TO THE
STAR -- LIKE I USED TO TELL
KEVIN AND DAN MARLEY, Y'ALL DO
Y'ALL THING.
>> I WOULD SAY THIS, CHUCK.
IF WE GO BACK TO TAPES OF YOU --
WAIT.
WE GO BACK TO TAPES OF CHUCK,
HE'S GOING TO BE LIKE THIS
SOMETIMES AND THEY'RE GOING TO
BE LOOKING YOU OFF BECAUSE THE
RESPONSIBILITY -- KEVIN WAS LIKE
NO, I CAN'T DO THAT EVERY TIME.
THAT'S THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO
LOOK YOU OFF --
>> DAN MAJERLE HE NEVER LOOKED
MY WAY.
HE'S GOING TO GET IT UP.
>> THE SERIES IS TIED TWO
APIECE.
PHOENIX, BY THE WAY, IN THOSE
TWO GAMES IN DALLAS DID NOT LEAD
IN THE SECOND, THIRD, OR FOURTH
QUARTERS OF EITHER OF THOSE
GAMES.
THE JA MORANT STORY NOW.
>> I'M GETTING SICK OF THE NBA
RIGHT NOW.
>> GRIZZLIES GOT BEAT BADLY BY
GOLDEN STATE LAST NIGHT.
JA WAS --
>> THAT PLAY?
>> THEY WERE COMPLAINING ABOUT
IT.
>> TAYLOR JENKINS COMPLAINED
ABOUT THAT.
>> I'M GETTING A LITTLE SICK,
MAN.
I'M SAKE OF TODAY'S PLAYERS.
EVERYTHING AIN'T NO CODE.
COME ON.
>> PROBABLY A REAL GOOD CHANCE
HE WON'T PLAY TOMORROW IN GAME 4
OF THAT SERIES.
AND JARED SAYS LOOK, I'VE BEEN
TOLD BY THE LEAGUE THEY
REVIEWED -- SOMEONE TOLD HIM
THAT THE LEAGUE REVIEWED THE
MORANT PLAY AT THE REQUEST OF
THE GRIZZLIES.
IT'S BEEN DETERMINED IT WAS I
ANORMAL BASKETBALL PLAY AND NO
FURTHER ACTION WILL BE TAKEN.
>> LIKE COME ON, MAN.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
I SAW HIM TOUCH --
>> SHOW IT AGAIN BECAUSE YOU CAN
SEE THAT HE REACHES.
BUT --
>> YEAH.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO REVIEW
EVERYTHING IN THE NBA NOW.
>> WATCH AGAIN.
DID HE PULL HIS KNEECAP BACK OR
SOMETHING?
>> THAT'S NOT -- MAN, HE
DIDN'T -- COME ON, MAN, NOBODY
TRYING TO HURT NOBODY.
>> WELL, JA IN FACT TWEETED OUT
THAT PLAY AND SAID BROKE THE
CODE, TAKING WHAT STEVE KERR
SAID ABOUT THE DILLON BROOKS
PLAY, AND THEN HE DELETED THE
TWEET.
>> I DISAGREE WITH STEVE KERR.
HE DIDN'T TRY TO HURT THAT KID.
>> SOMEBODY ANSWER MY QUESTION?
DID HE PULL HIS KNEECAP OUT
OF --
>> NOBODY TOLD US.
>> DILLON BROOKS THAT WAS A
FLAGRANT TWO.
BUT THE NOTION HE TRIED TO HURT
THAT KID I'M NOT GOING TO LIVE
WITH THAT.
AND THIS IS THE CODE?
MAN, GIVE ME A BREAK.
MAN.
>> ARE YOU GETTING FRUSTRATED,
CHUCKSTER?
>> EVERY CALL -- ERNIE, I'M
WATCHING A BASKETBALL GAME.
LET'S SEE IF IT'S A FLAGRANT.
LET'S SEE IF IT'S A FLAGRANT 1.
I'M LIKE YO, MAN, I'VE BEEN
KISSED HARDER THAN THAT.
>> WE ALL KNOW ABOUT YOUR SEX
LIFE.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT DILLON BROOKS --
>> HEY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU SAID THE TWO MAGIC WORDS.
SEX LIFE.
WE'LL BE BACK.
Starts with fresh grilled
chicken, hand cut cilantro,